elle a 32 ans et elle se promène un peu
partout à travers le pays son objectif
faire élire des députés anti avortement
en octobre prochain
quand elle ne recrute pas des bénévoles
calgary vancouver avec globe fait du
porte à porte ou distribuent des tracts
right now c'est le nom de son
organisation a été créée il ya trois ans
spécifiquement pour avoir une influence
politique
moins prolixe on peut vraiment changer
les choses si on prend part au processus
politique dans le passé le mouvement pro
vie a mis l'accent sur les
manifestations
c'est bien mais si on passe ce temps là
à faire du porte à porte pour un
candidat on risque d'avoir un meilleur
retour sur notre investissement
cette stratégie le groupe ragueneau l'a
déjà testé avec succès lors d'élections
provinciales récente en ontario le
groupe a contribué à l'élection de
candidats comme ça à master un
progressiste conservateur maintenant
assistant parlementaire du gouvernement
en alberta la nomination d'une ministre
de l'éducation prouvy a aussi réjoui les
groupes comme renault
même si la principale intéressée ne veut
pas confirmer avoir reçu leur appui
[Musique]
pour la prochaine élection fédérale le
groupe nous explique alice a de retour
dans son bureau à cibler 50
circonscriptions à travers le canada les
canadiens souvent ne savent pas comment
fonctionne une course à l'investiture
donc ce qu'on dit à nos supporteurs
c'est vous pouvez obtenir votre carte de
membre d'un parti et ainsi aider à
choisir un candidat pro vie
officiellement right now est une
organisation non partisane même si les
candidats qu'elle a pu en général sont
conservateurs et puis le groupe refuse
de révéler publiquement quelle
circonscription il cible par crainte que
les candidats fassent l'objet d'une
contre campagne
donc c'est le livre que vous avez écrit
sur l'avortement oui c'est un livre que
j'ai coécrit et je me demandais est ce
que le mouvement anti avortement canada
en ce moment est ce que c'est un
mouvement qui prend de l'ampleur
je sais pas si c'est un mouvement qui
prend l'ampleur
oui c'est un mouvement qui est beaucoup
plus stratégique et selon cette
politologue même si un plus grand nombre
de députés pro vie était élu leurs
influences risque d'être limité les
chefs conservateur comme un gros chien
hodgson kenny ont promis de ne pas
rouvrir le débat sur l'avortement
surtout près de 80 % des canadiens sont
pour le libre choix en fait qu'au canada
le pouvoir est vraiment concentrés dans
l'exécutif alors même si beaucoup de
députés arrière pas son allure ils vont
pas avoir beaucoup de pouvoir sur la
politique
[Musique]
la stratégie politique des militants
pro-vie soulève quand même des
inquiétudes qui est hybride qui est
propriétaire d'une microbrasserie dans
le sud de l'alberta s'est fait avorter
en janvier une décision difficile mais
pour elle la seule qui s'imposait à
lethbridge où j'habite c'est impossible
de se faire avorter
et pourtant on est une ville de sens
mais l'habitat il faut conduire plus de
deux heures jusqu'à calgary
c'est vraiment frustrant même si le
débat n'ait pas rouvert au canada
qu'elle qui craint des députés pro vie
exercent des pressions pour limiter le
financement ou l'accès à l'avortement
qui déjà très restreint dans certaines
régions du pays
pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit encore avoir
cette conversation l'avortement c'est
réglé ça fait des décennies que c'est
réglé
je souhaite régler ou non le mouvement
pro-vie n'entend pas lâcher prise
les prochains mois seront un véritable
test pour leur engagement politique
[Musique]